all right Juju yep Juju uh where'd you
grow up where are you from Inglewood
California
where Inglewood California Englewood
yeah and tell me about your family
growing up
um I was raised by my grandma my mom was
in and out of jail
and I don't know my father so yeah
can we just grab your childhood in
general
um it was cool I was raised around like
a bunch of kids I have a lot of like
brothers sisters
so
I have an adopted entire family they
raised me for the most part on the
weekends
um
yeah it was pretty it was decent normal
childhood no no terrible abuse or like
that
um I want to say a little bit emotional
abuse
um but other than that yeah I've heard
you in school huh how far did you go in
school how far I graduated uh High
School
yeah that's about it how'd you get into
this line of work
um I got turned out
when you were
after you graduate
um I want to say like
I've been doing it for
seven months I'm 23 so when I was 22.
yeah
how'd that happen
um
how did it happen
I was just getting asked if I wanted to
make a different type of money
opportunity
but were you working what were you doing
before
what was I doing before I was doing made
work
uh Camp counseling kids
I worked in an ice cream shop
and uh what else do I do a little stuff
for my mom's Law Firm
how does the money compare now to what
you're
um
it always
all the stuff I've done before yeah yeah
tell me about your first time
my first turning a trick turned into
trick
how was my first time okay I was ready
to go
um
wasn't trying to do any cheap dates I
was ready to go and then somebody told
me if I wanted to make a hundred dollars
and I said yep
and follow them to a spot
are you working with a with a pimp or no
uh I do you do yeah what are the
advantages of that uh you the advantages
of it it's like an assistant in a way
little personal assistant an assistant
who takes all your money
um not quite it's like a money manager
too
you get it back you do yeah
how much I mean
you get half of it back half of it yeah
and then you live off the rest so it's
not that bad we're staying in a motel or
uh where do you live I stay in a motel
now
yeah I just left my apartment like four
months ago five yeah do you have kids no
no kids
tell me about the uh the guys that are
your customers
um they're all right sometimes
sometimes I feel like they're slow for
me like they can move a little bit
faster but they just be wanting their
time
but um
for the most part they're okay
they're mostly Mexican unfit
I want to say mostly Mexican most
Mexican faces
and you guys are going to a motel or a
car or either or yeah
emotionally what is this how does this
work affect you
emotionally how does this work affect
you how does the word affect me the work
the work
um
emotionally working as a prostitute does
it affect you in any way
um well I feel like me kind of already
being like
from like how I grew up it was a certain
type of pressure that had to be a
certain type of way
so I feel like the pressure is is there
sometimes but
it's not really you know it's not too
bad you're okay with it yeah
are drugs are part of your life drugs
marijuana that's it that's it a little
bit of alcohol
a little bit
and uh
working fig is that uh
tell me about being on the street
um being on the street what are the
hassles I know there's things you go
through there
the hassles
um at first I didn't really like fig all
too much I felt like it was just a waste
of time
but um after a while when I kept pulling
back up to food
um
I just tend to do my own thing and it
works it works out if you had any better
bad experiences
bad experiences uh yeah
I can't lie like two days ago
they ran out the car took my little
purse with 85 dollars in it I just got
me some condoms so yeah
it wasn't too bad charged it to the game
but yeah
but were there other things you wanted
to do with your life
uh yes there is what would you like to
do I want to be a cosmetologist
you can still do that I know you're
young yeah are you just hoping to save
some money and yeah that's what it is
and get a little program be more stable
you know
have like certain things in order and
didn't get myself situated into school
have you been in love before in love
I want to say that yeah
before I started
um this I was in a relationship but um
got weird
yeah with the fact that you're doing
this now
get in the way of that kind of
relationship
actually the relationship that I was in
I was in a relationship I wasn't doing
this I left the relationship started
doing this and I went back to the
relationship
but I I see things for what it is when I
went back like I can you know tell
things did change
um they got comfortable with me making
so much money so that was one thing I
didn't really
like too well like I don't want nobody
else's to like if I'm taking care of
like people with what I do I don't want
their motivation to be like oh I don't
have to work for myself or you know I
don't have to do too much you know too
much work out here but that's all I do
is work
yeah so all you do is work yeah and
they're they're feeding off you yeah
that's the only issue like don't think
I'm you know expect to you know see too
much out of this so fast but
yeah what kind of
relationships did you see as a kid
growing up your dad wasn't around
um I had a stepfather he did a good job
of raising me with my um
my grandma actually that's my what do
you call a step Granddad I call my
Grandma Mom at one point and him dead so
that's why I say that
and um it was pretty cool but when they
had their own little problems you know
how that [__] goes you see problems in
the household
what's the hardest part of this this job
for you hardest part
um
okay
I want to say when you make a certain
type of money
and you're trying to maintain like your
lifestyle or whatever you're already
trying to like accomplish
and
I want to say money is not the same
every day so you can't get used to like
however much money you make on certain
type of days because you don't you don't
always get that walk in the streets oh
yeah
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about
women that do this kind of work
um
I was
all the way too down for it but when I
heard the benefits of like
you can always use a condom I was kind
of down free
I was down for it yeah and the money was
there so it's not I think you think
prostitution should be legalized
yes
I hear every like all the people I date
they go through stuff with their own
like
you know stuff at home they just need to
get that like that little lonely time in
or whatever a lot of your
um a lot of your customers are married
um I want to say half have girlfriends
or wives yeah
makes you wonder whether people are
supposed to be monogamous or not
when there's so many people sneaking
around yeah
what's your biggest regret in your life
my biggest regret
I don't think I have any
everything is a learning experience
how do you think working the streets is
changing you
it's changing me to grow up a little bit
a lot of it actually
so you see men differently now yes
through a lot of perspectives
can you trust a man again after seeing
what you've seen I
that was a tough one
um you just gotta find somebody that you
trust and if it becomes like
just weird or like you feel like
somebody's keeping secrets than just to
go at your gut and move a little bit
different because I feel like it helps
like when your peace of mind like you
know you don't feel played like all the
time or having having somebody you trust
is everything yeah
what advice would you give to a woman
who's thinking about doing this
advice
watch your surroundings
don't stand in the street too much
um
when you're interviewing
to
um interviewing meaning when a guy's
pulling up on you and yeah if somebody
wants to talk to you make sure they're
not a weirdo like you know I want to
make sure you can take advantage of them
before they can take advantage of you
you have to use your intuition a lot
don't you yeah
you guys have to develop a keen sense of
who's
worth spending your time with and who
isn't yeah
yeah that's a major key
major major key Juju what would you say
is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
lesson I've learned in my life important
important lesson damn there's so many of
them
I don't know
I really ought to think about that one
important lesson that I learned in my
life
I want to say
it's good to be humble and with a good
spirit at all times
I feel like that's
very good to have
yeah it gets you out of a lot of
situations and whatever you're going
through a lot quicker
keeping a good attitude yeah
all right Juju thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck out there be careful all
right thank you